prüfung tag und goethe stadt deutsch 1
das komplette vokabular mit dialogen
lektion 2
47 wörter
los geht's
die entschuldigung
die post
also
durch
entschuldigung
ja
wo ist die post bitte
also es ist so
am besten gehen sie durch die
bahnhofstraße
also es ist so
am besten gehen sie durch die
bahnhofstraße
über
links
gerade aus
weit
gehen sie hier über die straße
gehen sie hier
die straße
dann gehen sie die nächste straße links
und dann gehen sie immer geradeaus bis
sie die post sehen
es ist nicht weit
wo
daneben
sehr
und wo ist die bank
sie ist gleich daneben
sehr
danke sehr
der job
die jobs
müssen
der tag
die tage
ich heiße davis
ich heiße david
ich habe einen neuen job bei der post
neuen job bei der post
ich muss jeden tag von 13 bis 17 uhr
arbeiten
die post die frau die frauen
der brief die briefe der absender
haben sie post für mich
ich bin frau becker
die post für mich
da ist ein brief für sie aber ohne
absender
die briefmarke die briefmarken
der beamte
die beamten
der empfänger die empfänger
ich möchte bitte drei briefmarken
fragen sie die beamt
fragen sie die beamten am 8
ich möchte bitte drei briefmarken
die empfänger wohnen in spanien
die postleitzahl
die adresse
die adressen
wie es meine postleitzahl
sagen
adresse sagen
hauptstraße 22
neuhausen
postleitzahl lautet 37
26 5
ihre postleitzahl lautet 37
die auskunft die auskünfte
der schalter
die bank
geschlossen
können sie mir auskunft geben
gehen sie bitte zum schalter 3
ja die bank schließt schon um 4 uhr
die bank schließt schon um 4 uhr
nein die bank hat am samstag geschlossen
die bank hat am samstag geschlossen
das ende
der anfang
überweisen
das konto
die unterschrift
unterschreiben
ich bekomme mein geld am des monats
ich bekomme mein geld am ende des monats
jetzt ist schon an beim nächsten monats
jetzt ist schon anfang nächsten monats
das geld überweisen wir morgen auf ihr
konto
hier fehlt noch ihre unterschrift
wo muss ich unterschreiben
der computer die computer
gehen
drücken
anklicken
automatisch
hast du deinen neuen computer bekommen
faltin 1
ich weiß nicht wie das geht
drück hier dann geht der computer an
drückt hier dann geht der computer an
dann musst du dein bild anklicken
nein nein
das geht nicht
du musst nichts weiter machen
der rest geht automatisch
alles
der arbeitsplatz die arbeitsplätze
fehlen
bitter
jetzt hast du alles für deinen
arbeitsplatz
nein
[Musik]
was fehlt dir
ein drucker
sprechen sie bitte leiser
weiter geht's im nächsten video